previously on the forest
it's a small gap in here but uh it's a
cave all right
all right we'll split up that's always a
good strategy
are you going the water wait there's a
person wait i'm going for wade
why did we actually split up why did we
actually do the splitting up oh please
tell me we're getting out of this cave
what is that there's a pit what where
over there
bob do not test something bob's
fantastic bob
i'm going to build a platform i'm going
to try to build a rope off of the
platform 31.
okay i got to build a sled but my cup my
car my okay
hey hey uh what happened to the sled
um i don't want to talk about it
and all those logs we shot i don't want
to talk about it
oh i'm dying of freezing no i made a
fire you can't kill me of freezing i'm
in fire
don't worry bob there's a sled of wood
heading your way
i am ready for it i believe where did
you go
i'm drying out right now by a fire i'm
in a cave climbing mostly upward
okay i'm i i see a uh there's a cave
entrance wait
whoa hey
yeah yeah yo yo hey hey
oh my god i'm gonna go down help help
they're really barely married to why
why do you get to punch through my
freaking chainsaw oh he's down
[ __ ] loud okay i'm coming mark okay
thank you
i think once i get out of here
successfully maybe we don't come over
here for a while until we're ready for
that i wish i had never seen this thing
it was very un
un-good it was ungood
bad even yeah i'm climbing up a long
rope and in the distance i just hear
[ __ ] come on how's your house how much
time you got mark
oh like maybe 10 seconds i'm outside
oh no i'm safe holy crap
mark i'm coming your way uh well about
that i
am actually a wizard
wow that's great man oh mark died
oh no holy [ __ ] you got me my god was
oh my god let's go home and save this
before anything else happens let's go
holy i want you to know i met somebody
special and i killed her for you so
thank you
thank you i appreciate that big if that
herd of them comes around
don't say anything man don't say a thing
let's go back home
and hunt lizards and build ridiculous
houses
no more caves never go to that hole ever
again i forgot
[ __ ] timmy yeah he's gone he is gone now
and i feel no remorse
there's a lot of bodies we could have
just burned for armor and bones that's
true
we're never fighting again so yeah we're
a peaceful people now
yeah we're gonna show them ways through
pure pacifism
they'll learn they will learn oh i see
your cabin your cabin is just this
bastion
i really appreciate it i'm gonna put a
bunch of light up there it'll be like a
homing beacon
i know that the home is displayed really
big on the hud anyway and we don't need
that at all
but but you know for realism's sake
yeah yeah yeah man yeah yeah man
oh you you did my you survived when mark
and i died then you survived to fall to
hell
well you died in the fall to hell but
then you survived i mean i jumped into
an enormous pit so maybe genius is too
strong
but then i got myself out of the pit
that i jumped into yeah it's pretty neat
yeah dory i'm gonna put some uh fire on
and
get some well i don't have any fresh
meat so i'm
i'm not gonna put anything on it but
it's some not fresh meat
going definitely i saw some blooms now
i'm eating some bloobs
it's a good day hey we got a lot on the
drying rack that's probably ready to go
so that's good
okay i've got something to hang on the
drying geckos never dry
is it just me or these things never dry
i i don't know if they
are bugged or what oh no you store them
you grab the dried leather they stay in
your inventory you got to eat them from
so they're all good oh wow i have three
dried lizards
oh that's nice i'm going to just get
some more light in this place because it
is
you know it's a little too gloomy we
need to we have a big
bonf never mind we no longer have a big
i don't know where that went that that
disappeared
before we came here i'm just going to
put some nice decorations you guys are
going to love these
all right thanks man
okay that's a little more homey
i got a bunch of meat my dudes
your meat bro it's coming in hot and
heavy
just hot okay i see all of the
delightful
light that you've created in our home
delightful i like this hey what's up
dudes
hey huh just coming up you know wanted
to say hi
are you up here where are you you up
here i just got here i just i'm
downstairs i just got back
did you guys care to take a siesta
are you making a couch up here hey
listen i'm just hanging out you know you
need
seven deer skin huh pretty expensive
investment
no well yeah i had most of them i just
you know i don't share with you guys
it seems like you were missing six i put
one in there for you oh well i
appreciate that that's nice that's nice
we can share when you're done
so we can both snuggle on it together oh
my gosh guys look at the lamp up here
it's adorable are we sleeping am i
screwing up sleeping
well bob mark's on his way back up now
i'm going down
his way down to me i'm down we're
sleeping
all right one of three sleep let me i'm
gonna
save just in case like the game crashes
or i don't know it's on the off chance
yeah
oh my god all right next cave i know
exactly where it is
ready here we go oh man i think going in
right now honestly we're probably better
prepared for the next game than we were
that one but
no i think we need a breather from the
cave but i'm not gonna call you on your
bluff i think we're ready
all right i'm gonna call you on your
bluff i'm gonna i don't know what i'm
gonna do
but you're bluffing
all right uh i'm gonna go hunt some
animals that's what i'm gonna do
lots of rest i'm with you i'm with you
they're hard to see in the tall grass
i should turn down my grass detail are
slang shots good for uh deer two
slangs uh they'll stun them if you if
you slingshot them they'll stop moving
like when you hit them with a regular
weapon so
it's a good way to like stick them in
place
there's other animals we need to harvest
for things we should find some boars
and uh crocodiles
i don't know what else we needed i don't
remember crocodiles are there
flying oh yeah there was a thing in our
journal about them somewhere
i just killed this one's friend bunny
right next to it oh that's so sad
man i wish your inventory didn't or your
weapons didn't take like an hour and a
half to change
holy nailed it i am really good at
killing these bunnies now i am
we need more rabbit skins for stuff i
don't know i'm just killing them for fun
man
you can make like pouches and things i
would assume the rabbit skin
might be useful i do a
small rock bag i'm sorry you're just
explaining that you derive pleasure from
murdering rabbit's mark i was trying to
people were stopping me i got a quiver
how do you do
bow graphic that was easy the arrows
seem like a pain in the i don't know how
you get feathers
oh you can make a warm suit from skins
too
yeah we definitely need skins baby whoa
i made bow arrow
i need more feathers god i gotta kill
beer bag in a warm suit
die bird die did you make a warm suit
wait
no no no no no no the amount of stuff
you have to get for that's kind of
ridiculous no
[ __ ] birds they don't know what's
hitting them oh my god these stupid
birds
oh my god these birds are wrong with you
stupid idiots are you just like shotting
the [ __ ] out of some birds
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no i found a deer that's not broken
that runs away when i stab
it oh man how are you gonna kill it
before it teaches the others how to
survive
give me a bird i need feathers to make
arrows why is that
why do arrows take five feathers that's
ridiculous
dunk right out of the air you take five
feathers because you make five arrows
wow hello all right dude i didn't know
that
it was amazing oh i have so many arrows
oh my goodness gracious i am just
absolutely laden down with delicious
meat my dudes
dude i'm soaking in bird meat and rabbit
meat they have no idea
literally i'm making them go extinct and
i am
happy about it they deserve it for how
stupid they are
exactly that's what i've always said oh
wait
the rabbit trap looks like it tripped is
there a rabbit in here
oh know i need to steam you caught an
aloe plant
that's not how this works
yeah we caught an aloe yes i don't
understand
i don't know man i'm done serious
i wish i could like you guys i won't
take it out you guys are just
ghosts check out the rabbit trap when
you get a chance you're right mark we
did
we caught it hello yeah didn't even know
those could uh
be captured like that i thought you had
to grow them or
find them what are you talking about
don't be crazy those are hard to
get you could farm the aloe like [ __ ]
we need aloe so bad i don't know
yeah maybe so yeah how would we get
seeds from it
you just gotta find enough of them right
there's definitely a place on the island
where there would be
seeds of those kinds well should we
harvest this one see if we can get seeds
yeah definitely but i don't know if they
have seeds they might not
aloe seed i got an aloe seed oh yes
we need to start an aloe farm i agree uh
fyi there are eight
more caves to explore oh my god i have
not
found you okay i saw it
i made us another drying rack because
we're literally so filthy rich with food
that we can afford
we need need
[Music]
oh my god the warm suit is sick
bambi
power
wait you can make a stick bag oh yeah oh
[ __ ] dude what do you need a stick bag
what do you need to make a stick bag is
that your skin rabbit skins cloth and
rope
really still rabbit skittles oh that's
not bad yeah hell yeah
my dude oh god it is one
all right i've got a stick bag now oh i
need rope god damn it
you make rope with cloth right yeah i'm
making it i just
don't like beans you may make a rabbit
we got that from the cave yeah a deer
where oh next to me
[ __ ] was that we got to finish your
couch man
get the deer oh there we go
from don't worry i got him how did that
hit me
did i hit you oh sorry a rock just came
tumbling over my head as if it was
bounced off my back i don't know
who did that that was weird let's get
those stupid birds
where are they i want birds i want to
upgrade you're getting feathers where do
you see feathers at the feathers are
separate
they'll like poof off of the bird you
can also get it from just scaring the
bird
sometimes they'll fly away and be all
[ __ ] yeah if you don't want to commit
murder birder if you will
good one man excellent one incredible so
let's see
about building expanding the like the
upstairs part of the base or something
yeah the upstairs part your part
did someone start a farm out here should
i start building a farm for the aloe
oh yeah get that aloe planted for
suresies oh this rabbit is
dunzo
why do these rabbits even try for how
fast i know rabbits to be in real life
these ones are idiots
[Music]
i mean i suppose after our adventure in
the cave feeling any sort of positive
about ourselves is good
i'll just make like a big aloe farm
right here why not man why not
there we go how's that i think it's
beautiful man i bought la
blah bro i brought a bro i put i put i
put this
i put the all right i got a log here
all right mark you might put that
together for me thanks
don't buddy there you go it's all done
it's all done
all right all right good work good work
you're good you got it all done
all right okay boss we'll go fill up the
logs
all right we have one aloe seed planted
hey it's a start so
mark where did you say aloe vera
typically spawns edge
i've seen it before in where the uh the
plane lands
so i don't know if it's still there i
just tried on a single player
uh little level and there was plenty
that was around that area
but again i mean it makes sense it would
be over there no wait there's more aloe
right here it's spawning down here now
oh hell yeah
there's two more plants of it right here
oh do you want to try to collect it
bob to see if you can see the seeds
separate sure where are they
literally i'm standing on it like right
now that's a rock
for me what weird
and so and where
uh i'll just collect them then i got one
more seed and two aloe vera
oh [ __ ] son how do we make a plaque oh
so aloe seeds are right next to the
blueberry seeds in your inventory they
look the same but it's like a separate
pile
all right well i have 30 blueberry bush
seeds but i don't think i have any
yellow
okay i'll keep looking for aloe and then
i guess if i'm the only one i'm the aloe
whisperer
oh i saw aloe i caught aloe
that's true you did catch them in the
bunny trap okay bob thoughts on this
oh wow that was sick i like that
that's awesome yeah too high up you want
a little lower
um well we could build this platform
over so it's sort of all in one level we
can do that i think that makes sense
yeah we can do that we can make that
happen i can make that happen for you i
can make that happen for you make my
dreams come true i will make you
absolute
beefcake of a man thank you what's
happening here sounds awfully uh
you don't need to worry about it someone
like you just doesn't need to worry
about it
can you define the parameters of someone
like me a person
with your staff yeah yeah all yeah
but bob's calling me i know that's the
point no whatever
exactly your height is that's the
problem height
i understand you don't need to anyway
bob i'll make this for you
i appreciate that do it i don't get why
you don't get sticks from cutting down
trees
i know i feel like that would make
plenty of sense most annoying thing in
the world
there's so much invisible aloe vera i
can collect all of a sudden
i what the hell happened you saw it so
now you have like this
the sixth sense you could see aloe vera
i can't even see it but i'm just walking
around and i see seed icons and i'm just
glad i figured there's a name for that
phenomenon i forget what it actually is
oh hey look more aloe it's just what is
going on
it's everywhere wait do you want to help
with this project of making uh
bob's home even more glorious well sure
yes do you want uh healy bandages that
help keep you alive
i wouldn't mind that's pretty cool yeah
that's pretty cool oh my god it became
dark
it is very dark uh i can't even see um
let's see what bedtime looks like it's a
bedtime almost bedtime you guys want to
snooze
yeah yeah we could make a big snooze
yeah no i know snooze and then finish up
this gazebo
how snoozy is snooze like times
it's like if you've got that size slice
of pie you'd be disappointed by how
small it is left
yeah so if you've got that slice of cake
you might be okay with it because cake's
inferior to pie is cake infuriated pie
though yeah
is it really though yeah
yeah that's that's what you said
like our wedding cake was really good
but like in general cake is just like
brownies are better
better pie is better guys cut into the
wedding pie
she's sleeping now i'm sorry yeah
look i love me a good pumpkin pie
there's like nothing
there but when you got things like
cheesecake
like you really can't make that many
comparisons to how
pie even just a good chocolate cake oh
yeah
it's basically superior to any
fruit-based pie not even close yeah
a good like double chocolate cake
there's no way that
on the whole all pie is superior to all
cakes
that's probably true there's the shitty
pies oh yeah and they're shitty there's
good
don't get me wrong yeah but we're if
we're comparing the greatest
pot total yeah if it was like a game and
it was
pie versus cake like battle she
always wins but i don't know man
dude death battle takes characters at
their peak of their power that's what
they do
and it's the only thing that can make it
fair even if you don't even know if
the best cake is better than the best
pie though
what would you call the best pie yeah
what would you call the best buy
i don't know i've had some good like see
i'm simple man i like i like my
dutch apples with the caramel drizzle i
don't know okay so you're a fruit-based
pie
guy right is this what you're getting
i'm not talking meat pies or you know no
it's fruit based as opposed to like
chocolate or pumpkin or coconut
pumpkin pie is good pumpkin pie is up
there but i don't know
there's something about like a good
apple pie that to me is a like s
z tier either why the apple pie is eater
apple pie is merely like
tolerable to me like apple pie is good
the fact that it can be made better by a
scoop of vanilla ice cream
does not make a strong i would argue
cake can too
cake doesn't need ice cream okay and it
can be made of ice cream
yeah it can be improved by ice cream
let's remove the ice cream really
good milk any ancillary items it would
have to stand up on its own
to have any qualifications like i i
consider pumpkin pie the best with
whipped cream but i i don't think i can
add that on there just to
make that pie i don't know what kind of
sociopath
pumpkin pie without whipped cream i know
i know it's kind of a given
i know yeah but the same with ice cream
and like dutch apple like a slice of a
scoop of ice cream with some
apple pie like that that's what i'm
saying together look at all the pairings
like
just a cake like the perfect cake
is just like uh it's a life-changing
experience well yeah if you fight
aquaman in the ocean he's going to have
the advantage but like who's picking
aquaman
that's just a nonsense straw man
argument
you can't put the pairings together with
what goes well with pie i don't know i
feel like you're
well if you're high it's inferior cake
doesn't need anything
cake is the superior cake i would still
take the pie
cake can have ice cream in it cake can
have jam in it kate can have
just ice cream all those options ice
cream cake i was considering those i
i think the range alone cheesecake
itself is just so good
it is like it really is horribly good
we talked to that baker in portland on
tour
what what was the decision cheesecake is
definitely
cake oh it's definitely okay okay maybe
if if that qualifies as pie which i
might be able to still remember wave you
were there for that do you remember that
i just forgot i don't remember what he
said but i do remember having a weird
discussion and we were like
all by it yeah i i feel like the
definitive answer was cheesecake was
cake because the baker had some specific
reasons they listed off
yeah probably some something in the
creation process but i forgot i like
carrot cake is game over for me if
there's carrot cake carrot cake
i might go out of my way my groom's cake
at our wedding not our wedding mark but
my manny's wedding
uh was a carrot cake and it was
delicious
yeah it was so good i don't recall it oh
who hates carrot cake oh my god everyone
in chat who thinks carrot cake is bad
your opinion is wrong get you'll get
your chase get your taste buds replaced
because something is going on with you
oh my god someone just said cheesecake
tastes nasty just like go away
like whatever cheesecake's really hard
to qualify because there's so many
variants
exactly you get to have your pick like
not everyone's a new york style
cheesecake kind of guy
but red velvet cheesecake from and
that's like a mixture of
like all the goodness so you get that
from cheesecake factory red velvet dude
that hershey chocolate one with the
chocolate chips on it from like
god i want to go to cheesecake
i've not been to a restaurant in so long
around a year since i've been to a
restaurant soon people probably but like
you see most people but i see a lot of
people
gotta be at restaurants most people i
care to talk to
all right so i i have to i have to like
raise a qualification someone's in the
chat was just like you dude
vegan oreo cheesecake is bomb and i'm
like i don't doubt you
i don't like and i'm not questioning
veganism at all but i'm just like
there's no way vegan oreo cheesecake
tastes better than straight up oreo
cheesecake
yeah like tofu chicken wings too and
they weren't bad but like it wasn't i'm
sorry are you talking about
melts tofu chicken wings because if
you're talking about
melts tofu chicken wings i have an issue
because they're amazing i've i've never
even added they're not amazing
they're not great yeah they're not
amazing for
tofu chicken wings they're amazing as a
thing to eat
they have a they were great right
if there were no chickens in the world
and i really wanted chicken wings i
would eat one again
but whilst i have an option another
option
i shall jesus christ
yeah yeah i cut down a big o yeah now i
have had
a like an incredible like just straight
up i think vegan pie
or vegan cake like a no egg no milk kind
of cake and it was delicious don't get
me wrong
but i'm just saying animal
murder cake it's like totally possible
to make vegan baked goods that are
really delicious
and i am 100 on board with that but i
feel like it gets a bad rap
at least in my from my perspective
because i watch a lot of cooking shows
and whenever it's like a baking show or
even just like
chopped or something like a cooking
competition yeah whenever there's a
person who's like yeah i'm all vegan or
like i'm all
whatever i'm vegetarian or whatever i i
always kind of like
root for them also they frequently are
not
as good which like maybe it's harder
which is entirely fair but i feel like
that's a bad representation because it's
so it's so doable to make delicious
satisfying vegan vegetarian food there
are definitely some delicious vegan
recipes and stuff like that
i've i've had some myself but when you
come from like
like a professional chef with a diverse
palette like
you're basically like handicapping
yourself from many flavors
uh when you're like i'm gonna make only
vegan and it's not that you can't make
those vegan recipes amazing like some
people have and some people will and
more people will always do that but
yeah but a lot of those cooking
competitions they do run into that
trouble
anyway we seem to have beaten way down
so yeah
the hot's still opinion uh by a two to
one vote
is that cake wins and pie is in no way
superior to cake
yeah i'm gonna have to give a big vote
i'm gonna use my one a year big
vote here you're a big boy vote
i'm using my big boy vote to make a tie
all right we
accept that you think that pie is
better than cake yeah if you want to say
that you think
it's disgusting and you like experience
well yeah that's acceptable
yeah just to say that all pi is better
than all cake
that's just not true it's just not i
don't know how you objectively do that
but like yeah i that's totally fine i've
just never been a big cake person i've
always found cake maybe it's just the
way i've had cake where it just always
seems dryer like brownies are usually
nice and moist
like fresh baked cookies are so good
i think all cake is dry but yeah you've
only had shitty cake because it's been
sweeping generally like if your
experience is that cake is dry
that's just shitty cake yeah cake is
supposed to be
as moist as brownies maybe a little less
but with the icing mixed in
like it's supposed to be very moist
not at all dry yeah it just sounds like
you've had like
meyer or kroger brand cakes from their
bakery
good cakes come on now i haven't had
kroger cake in a while maybe they're
good but
my favorites cakes are delicious my
experience has not been too pleasant
i just know if i was like hungry enough
for one dessert and there was a really
good cake next to a really good pie or a
really good cookie or brownie
the cake would probably be the last one
i would take
that's crazy boom it's done
holy [ __ ] i'm just out here filling up
the sludge all right well there's no
more aloe
spawning so i can come help you guys
boom look at this look at this
king of the castle okay what is that
wow yeah
nice this is nice this is lovely look at
the view
this is beautiful man yeah it's pretty
cool wow i think there's a job well done
man
wow well the wind uh effect up here is a
little intimidating
yeah it's blowy oh my god you could just
cut a hole do not go hold on
hold on
now
what the hell
you